[Music]
[Applause]
david carr nfl network analyst former
nfl quarterback
and uh he joins us now the
thursday night game by the way cowboys
without their head coach mike mccarthy
against the saints on fox nfl network
and amazon prime video and david kind
enough to join us
um
how important is that head coach when
you make your decision to go play
oh it's extremely important i mean
you've seen when
lincoln left
oklahoma how many top five recruits and
just five stars said you know i'm going
with him or i'm gonna go somewhere else
it's it's
vitally important coach i'm a huge
believer in coaching i mean
it doesn't matter what level you're at
it could be high school football
you can give your kids an extreme
advantage just by
the x's and those that you draw up so
you know it goes beyond that as well it
goes
to the the type of person that the guy
is
i mean there's so many different levels
to it but to think that you know
all these guys can just roll out there
and it's just a matter of will and it's
a matter of just being tougher than the
other guy that's crazy you can do so
much just with x's and o's in the scheme
you can create offense for your
quarterback you can make it easy for
your offensive line you can make it also
extremely difficult so
yeah i mean coaching is coaching is
everything
did usc recruit you
no and i'm really upset about it you
know what i am going to go i'm going to
spring ball because lincoln he's not
going to be able to keep me off that
field i got i have to i have to see this
thing first this is uh i told willie
mcginnis yesterday we were doing our
show i said look man i don't i'm just
tagging along so you're gonna have to
deal with it because i steal lincoln's
plays all the time running for my high
school football team so you're
definitely bringing me with you but you
know
sc did in washington did but then
ironically we just lost our coach at
fresno state to washington so you know
and happens everywhere okay what do you
see you say you steal plays when you
coach uh with lincoln riley what what is
separating him from a lot of these other
coaches
i was talking to derek about this last
night because we we both almost just
left football and talking about football
to go coach based on just some of the
numbers that we're hearing from this guy
but
honestly when you watch his scheme it's
not that difficult um but it's brilliant
because he has subtle changes and tony
dungy was like this tony dungy when he
was
the coach for the colts they on the
surface it looked like they were only
playing cover two or cover three every
snap but in reality there were subtle
changes that they would make to the
front to the linebacker's
responsibilities to the corners
responsibilities so and it would match
what you do and try to effectively take
away what you're able to do
from an offensive standpoint
and lincoln's the same way when you
watch his offensive schemes it looks
like he only runs five plays but those
five plays have so many different
tweaks and combinations and
the brilliance of what he does is he'll
show you something and you'll say oh i
got it and they'll just be a double move
off of it or there'll be you know
another element to the play so it's
almost like um just another example the
seattle seahawks they used to play a ton
of cover three just single high and
everybody's like oh we know what they're
doing but no one could complete passes
against them no one could move the
football it's because the seattle
seahawks knew exactly what they would
get versus that coverage they knew what
you were going to try and do so you know
lincoln's brilliance is he's going to
run stuff that looks exactly the same
as everything you've seen on film he's
going to hit you with a double move he's
going to hit you with a screen out the
back side he's going to hit you with
something that you just didn't expect
you're like oh well that's just a
one-off well he does it all the time so
that's that's the brilliance of what of
what he does is
on the surface it's simple it's easy to
understand from an offensive uh
standpoint from a player just wants to
roll in
you're you're a top you know you're a
five-star recruit you want to play
receiver you can easily go in and play
in his system you know it's not a it's
not a big learning curve but but what he
does is his subtle changes during the
game are just brilliant
best coaching job right now oklahoma
notre dame
lsu usc
i mean i i don't know how
just think about what sc used to do to
those sec teams i think we forget that
sometimes you know when they when when p
was there
um they would just go in and just bounce
those guys and i know we talked about
scc a lot and that's a fantastic
conference and those guys
obviously uh
have some of the best players and you
can make an entire football team hunter
info
who believes that clemson could actually
win like two or three games every year
in the nfl which i mean he's absolutely
certain about it so i get that but i i
don't know how you can just take the
kids in la
and if you don't let them leave and you
keep them at sc you'll win the national
championship every year you know so i
think that's a great job i don't know
why
i mean i'm sure i'm not alone here but
why do you leave notre dame for lsu you
know if you're
brian kelly it's crazy to me i don't
understand that maybe i grew up in a
different era where notre dame was
the job that you would want to have
forever but i i feel like he had a
pretty good gig up there so that's going
to be really interesting to see how that
plays out well lsu from what i'm told
reached out to brian kelly prior to the
start of this season and he said no
i think he wanted to be the all-time
leader in wins at notre dame which he
did this year and then then i think at
age 60 then maybe he was open to the
prospects of of going someplace else i
think the nfl was always sort of there
whether he wanted it or nfl teams were
interested but but lsu did reach out to
start this season from what i'm told in
brian brian said no
yeah um i i'm trying to understand
seattle here david because i i watch
russ and russ is a hall of fame
quarterback
pete carroll's
maybe a hall of fame head coach i don't
know
but yeah
i i watch them and i
i i don't know who they are what they
are they were 12 and four last year i
don't know who they are this year and if
you're russell wilson and you're looking
around going
what am i doing like my legacy is at
stake here and we're not going we're not
going forward we're going backwards so
what is wrong with the seahawks
it's a hard watch so what they did okay
so you know pete carroll has always
wanted to run the football play good
defense all right so i mean you can
start on the defensive side and you can
say that they've gotten away from their
personality not to keep bringing up
willie mcginnis but he's a defensive
genius in my opinion played for one of
the best defensive coaches of all time
new england patriots and when he watches
the seattle seahawks he gets visibly
sick because he knows what they used to
be he knows that they used to play a
certain way and they've gotten away from
their identity they don't just play
single high cover three with the kind of
matching coverages underneath they just
try to do a whole bunch of stuff they
blow coverages it's not the same so then
you go on the offensive side of the ball
and they've always been a team that runs
the ball at least 50 percent of the time
they've led the league in run percentage
pretty much since russell wilson and all
those guys but you think about marshawn
lynch i mean they were pounding the
football you know and russ was involved
in that from the shotgun
and they were kind of at the forefront
honestly even before teams were really
doing a lot of zone runs and involving
the quarterback in that they they were
doing that with russ
and and for some reason they decided
that they looked around the league and
they saw this offensive uh
scheme that's happening you know with
the rams and with the 49ers and now with
the packers and it's like that sean
mcvay and kyle shanahan
wide zone play action pass and they're
like you know if we can and in theory
this makes sense if we can do that we're
going to run the ball anyway let's run
the outside zone let's pound the rock
let's play action pass buy rust some
time back there that the time that he's
always kind of created for himself and
we'll buy some time to make some big
shots down the field and in theory it
sounded good and i think you can even
hear like when when you talk to russ or
you hear him in the interviews now like
he's excited about what shane waldron
the offensive coordinator from the rams
is is able to kind of put on paper the
problem is it doesn't translate because
you have a quarterback and the rams are
going through this too
with matt stafford you have a
quarterback that is one of the better
just drop back pass
quarterbacks in the league that is able
to see the field and and kind of
delegate and
kind of really dictate what he's going
to do from the pocket and when you turn
your back to the defense it's no longer
on russ it's on your play calling and
it's on the scheme
to kind of carry that load and you saw
the rams kind of get away from it
they're doing more drop back pass and
you could argue that it's hurting them a
little bit they've lost a little bit of
that physical element
the seahawks are no different they're
just not as talented so they're trying
to do this outside zone run stretch
they're not really sold on it you can
even see the offensive lines not even
sold on it because they're not really
doing it you know they're not really
pushing the pile they don't they'll
crack a couple runs then they'll just
scrap it they'll go right to the drop
back pass game and the other thing when
you have a when you run that offensive
system
you tend to have better zone run
blocking guys you know even like terrell
davis used to tell me dude if we had to
drop back pass even when oe was there
based on the offensive line that we had
we were going to get beat we were going
to have a hard time but if we could keep
that run going we could play action off
of it we'd have success same thing with
the seahawks the problem is
shane waldron is a young offensive
coordinator russell wilson is a is a
very vocal um
experienced quarterback and rightfully
so he's going to say what he wants to do
and he's always going to default to let
me just do my thing from the pocket
the problem is they have an identity
crisis so they don't know who they are
on the offensive side that's why it's
hard to watch that's why it's difficult
because they don't even know really what
they want to do and their best plays are
still with russ just kind of making
things happen but the problem is that's
not an offensive scheme you can hang
your hat on and they're kind of just
trying to figure it out right now and
that's why it looks so bad
david great to talk to you as always we
appreciate your insights thanks for
joining us
you got it buddy thanks that's david
carr he works for the nfl network and
thursday night it'll be the cowboys
saints on fox nfl network and amazon
prime video